these days it seems like we want to have
fun
all the time everyone has a plan for
making work fun making learning fun
making laundry fun and it's become so
common and so cloying it's almost enough
to make you want to swear off fun
forever games are perhaps the only
medium daft enough to measure their
aesthetic value with a nebulous concept
like this like fun and as a result
games tend to be seen as a form of black
magic we know that they have a power
over people we can't quite characterize
that power which makes us desperate to
control it you know educators wonder
what are all my students doing in
minecraft all day and parents wonder why
can my kid lead a world of warcraft
guild but can't finish his homework and
all of us wonder why are we so addicted
to candy crush
and we tend to think that games are
powerful because they deliver this
payload of fun we think we want to have
fun everywhere
but what does it mean to make something
fun do we even know what it means if you
wanted to design a fun toaster or a fun
tasting menu or a fun conference talk
how would you go about it we've
misunderstood fun to mean something like
enjoyment without effort and that's why
every activity now has someone trying to
gamify it as the consultants keep saying
to make it fun to turn it into a
delightful morsel of sugar in your mouth
and in fact it's with that morsel of
sugar that many of us first learned
about how games supposedly make things
fun thanks to that great philosopher of
fun mary poppins
so if you remember how the the mystical
victorian nanny assures the bank's
children she says a spoonful of sugar
helps the medicine go down and this song
rehearses our understanding of fun as
enjoyment as opposed to misery
essentially what mary poppins is
suggesting is covering over drudgery
just as the robin's song supposedly
hides the boredom of nest building or
something and the popping song hides the
boredom of cleanup
but actually a spoonful of sugar tells
us so little about fun that it's kind of
embarrassing we've let the song get away
with it for so long
in every job that must be done there is
an element of fun you find the fun and
snap
the is a game that sounds great right
but just try to follow this advice i
dare you
if an element of fun is hidden in every
job then how do you find it
where do you look by what process does
the job become again do i just snap is
that it do i need to hire my own
supernatural nanny
a spoonful of sugar turns out to tell us
what we already know it's just a
tautology a job seems more fun if it
seems more fun
mary poppins was selling snake oil it
turns out
games and fun are connected not because
games are intrinsically enjoyable
but games are fun because they are
experiences we encounter through play
and play is the act of manipulating
something that doesn't dictate all of
its capacities but that does limit many
of them so minecraft asks you to survive
in a world made of these inhospitable
cubes that you can use as resources and
candy crush asks you to solve puzzles
given a limited supply of powers
and play it turns out isn't limited to
games at all it's everywhere it's in
anything we can operate
a mechanism like a steering wheel has
some play built-in room through which
the steering shaft moves to turn the
pinion
play isn't an act of diversion but a
name for making something work for
interacting with its materials and
that's why we also say that we play an
instrument or a sport
there's an old aphorism about golf that
calls it a good walk spoiled
and it's meant as a joke of course but
it underscores something fundamental
games make no sense
and yet we take them seriously precisely
because they make no sense the
philosopher bernard sweets calls it the
voluntary attempt to overcome
unnecessary obstacles
there's something unreasonable something
something foolish about playing games
and as it happens this is where the word
fun actually finds its origins in
foolishness
the middle english word that would
become fun means a fool or to make a
fool of like you might say don't poke
fun at me
and the medieval fool the gesture or the
trickster
was not reckless this was an
honest-to-god job being a fool was a
commitment the fool was expected to see
life differently in fact queen elizabeth
is even said to have rejoined her fools
for not being critical enough of her
reign
what the fool does is ask what else is
possible and then carries out even the
most outlandish answer
that takes a kind of shrewdness it's not
a witness practice it requires this
painstaking attention to detail
to find something new in a familiar
situation not this anything goes
carelessness that we usually think of
when we think of fun
in fact the fool teaches us that fun
requires a greater commitment to
everyday life not not a lesser one at
all and fun isn't a feeling it turns out
it doesn't involve making something easy
or by rewarding it with points as if
life is some latent version of space
invaders
instead
fun means deliberately manipulating a
familiar situation in a new way
and we can only have fun once we've
accepted the truth of that situation
treated it for what it is golf isn't a
good walk spoiled it's a way to
transform landscapes into a
centuries-long hobby and like golf the
things that we tend to find the most fun
are not easy and sweet like the banks's
clean up routine i mean manual
transmissions and knitting are fun
because they make driving and fashion
hard rather than easy they expose the
materials of vehicles and fabrics and
they do not apologize for doing so
there's a kind of terror in real fun
this terror of facing the world as it
really is
rather than covering it up with sugar
and this is where mary poppins leads us
astray a spoonful of sugar it hides
something it turns it into a lie it
assumes that the subject of our
attention can never be sufficient on its
own
when you think about it a job is made
fun not by turning it into a game
but by deeply and deliberately pursuing
it as a job jobs are fun when their work
is meaningful when their activities
matter when the act of conducting them
can be done over and over again with
increased adeptness
so fun can't be added to something no
more than chocolate turns broccoli into
dessert but you can design and use
things with enough resistance to allow
this capacity for play and every now and
then they reward you
for doing so in 2010 at wimbledon for
example john isner and nicholas mahut
played a match of tennis for three days
neither one was able to break the other
service to tip the match out of
equilibrium and both of the players
served over 100 aces issner finally
bested mahut with a 70-68 final set was
completely ridiculous
they found something in tennis the two
of them that nobody had found before as
if they were unearthing a fossil
two well-matched players could make
tennis go on almost forever
they coaxed the sport to give up this
secret because they treated it with such
absurd respect that the game couldn't
help but release it and this is what fun
looks like at its best
but you don't need to be a tennis pro to
access it
anyone can play anything with the
deliberateness that produces fun for
example each morning you grind your
espresso beans and you unclump and tamp
them to the right weight in density
which you've discovered over many other
mornings and then you time temperature
regulated hot water through the group
head to produce this 27 second pole that
you've timed and it balances sourness
against bitterness and the particular
roast you've chosen but then next week
you choose a new grind or a new tamp to
to work with a new blend
on tuesdays you go out with your friends
and even with the same company at the
same bar with the same hot wings the
same complaints about the same
co-workers
each evening results in some new
discovery the way a sense of humor
responds to a particular story the way a
face blankets a new worry with a
familiar gentleness
on sunday you mow the lawn and you use a
manual reel mower to reduce noise to
connect yourself physically to the
active mowing but
the blades catch short on your uneven
plot and so over many sundays you
discover a pace that allows you to keep
their momentum through the switchbacks
and while struggling to maintain that
control you refine the straightness of
your lawn stripes over the months over
the seasons
fun comes from the attention and care
you bring to something that offers
enough freedom of movements enough play
that such attention matters and even
seemingly stupid boring activities can
be fun in the process maybe especially
stupid boring activities can be
feeling that you are having fun at
something is a sign that you've given it
respect
and we fail to have fun we fail to
design for it too because we don't take
things seriously enough
not because we take them too seriously
minecraft is fun because it's not trying
to be anything but minecraft it's not
trying to be minecraft for physics
education or minecraft for laundry
but imagine if physics and laundry took
their practices as seriously as
minecraft takes minecrafting
imagine if all the people trying to add
fun to their products and services
redoubled their commitment to the
experience of using them
instead and that's how you design fun by
treating the thing you are making or
doing as exactly what it is
fun isn't a kind of pleasure at least
it's not a direct kind of pleasure
fun is giving respect to something that
doesn't deserve it
becoming infatuated with something for
which infatuation seems
impossible
just by working it carefully and
deliberately over time
in the hopes that it might someday blush
before you
and reveal its secrets
thank you
you